Now let us consider another situation. Suppose that our pitcher actually
was able to walk the batter. So, now, there are runners on the first, second,
ands third bases. Not just on the second and third bases, but one on the first,
also. So the picture succeeded in accomplishing it's goal in the last shot.
So the current situation then is discard, but this side of percept and
this goal. The confidence of the working memory have just changed. Of course,
the production rules capturing the pursuit of knowledge have not yet
changed. So these are exactly the same productions that we had previously.
Only the contents of the working memory has changed.
We now have a runner at the first as well as the second and
the third. And this exercise is very intrusting because it will lead us
to a different set of conclusions. Given the set of precepts in this goal and
the set of production rules, what operator do you think the picture will select?